[Music]
hola migente good morning it's not the
morning it's afternoon but i just woke
up because my sleep schedule has been
out of whack let me fill you in on
what's been going on in this household
um
by the way i'm 30 weeks
here's a bump update
30 week belly there's been a lot going
on um but we haven't really picked up a
camera to really bring you guys along
because it's just like just dealing with
things already is one thing and then
having to record it is a whole nother
thing so it's better if we just tell you
in retrospect for starters i have been
sleeping alone
for over a week because casey he caught
a cold
and he caught like this really like
incessant cough that won't go away
um but it's not covered don't worry got
tested it's not covered it's just calm
and cold and so in order to
make sure that i don't get sick he's
been sleeping in the office for over a
week now and so i've been in my bed my
lonely bed well at least i have my body
pillow but
but yeah so that's kind of been crazy
because i've been making him breakfast
every morning
and like making his chamomile tea with
like lemon and honey to try to help his
throat
and that cough of his and also avoid me
getting sick because me coughing while
being pregnant oh my goodness no like no
so we are doing everything on our power
to make sure i do not catch whatever it
is that he got and luckily it's been
working it's been like so far so good i
haven't gotten it like gotten anything
so yeah that's pretty much what's been
going on in this house other updates
is i put some stuff up around the room i
don't know if you notice so this tiny
little clock oh my god this clock look
how freaking small this is okay when i
purchased it on amazon it showed to be
like pretty much the size of the like
the length of the tv
and like it would have been like about
this big
but look how freaking tiny it is look at
this
come on
it's so small read the description
people and if it's in centimeters don't
be lazy like me and don't convert it
because that's what happened they gave
me the measurement in centimeters i'm
like i'm not gonna convert this i don't
know centimeters who knows i'm a lazy
american so anyway i purchased it i got
it super tiny i was like you know what
i'm still gonna put it up where i
intended it to be which is here casey
says i should move it here which i
probably will eventually but i just been
too lazy and literally the next day i
put it up at night time and then in the
morning when i woke up i was like wait
it's nine o'clock it should be earlier
because my phone says it's like seven
something the freaking clock broke it
broke it's stuck at nine pm every time i
see it i'm just like
i gotta get rid of it it upsets me but
you know what makes me really happy
though in this bedroom is this look
casey bought me this uh beautiful canvas
portrait of a photo from our wedding
it's actually my favorite photo of us
recently i put together a photo album
that i showed you guys and i was telling
casey i'm like oh man i was really stuck
between that other photo that has the
eiffel tower in it to be the cover or
this one and i picked the other one
because it has the eiffel tower in it
it's like okay we got married in paris
might as well show it but this photo is
just so like intimate and like it
captures such a beautiful moment of
happiness from our wedding day that i
just i absolutely love and so casey
surprised me like a few days after my
birthday this came in and he was like
yeah this is also your birthday present
slash christmas cause it's early
christmas present so we put it above our
bed and i see it every day especially
these days that i'm not sleeping next to
him and i just look up and i'm like oh
my hubby he's right there so it makes me
really happy and this is what happens
when my husband is left to his own
devices so for starters he set up this
tray which is really cute he set up this
tray
and then he put these little notes he's
like you can drop
you can drop off things here thank you
love you so this is where i've been
leaving his tea and his toast every
morning i thought that was really cute
because he was like wait don't come up
yet i'm setting something up and it
turns out it was this
but yeah so
this is the it's actually not bad right
now he cleaned up
nice i feel so bad for casey because
this is so uncomfortable compared to our
actual bed and i keep telling him to put
this out because this is a foldable like
memory foam mattress so this is really
comfortable and this is what we use when
we have guests come over we'll put it
over this futon and he's like no it's
just too too much work to put it out but
i'm like dude it's not comfortable so
he's been suffering but i don't know
that's his decision i also gave him the
air purifier here so i'm like purify all
your nasty uh contagious coughing in
this room and during the day he always
leaves the window open too to like kind
of air it out
so that's been the process here
oh cute
he's outside putting the ornaments on
these little trees so christmas is this
week just so you guys know the time
frame
and i was too lazy to put out all these
ornaments out here because this is what
we did last year
in case he kept saying that we should do
it and i was like no it's okay it's
almost christmas it's not a big deal we
can just skip this year they're gonna
get wet anyway because it's been raining
and he's like no i really want to do it
so that's so adorable he's doing it now
because i actually decorated
like all
all of our decorations here
um i did most of it i did have him help
me a little bit here and there but we
finally have a christmas tree this year
finally that's how isaac used to say
finally we finally have a christmas tree
this is a pencil tree so it fits in this
little corner and i got one where the
bottom doesn't have any like leaves and
so we're able to still have the kitty
litter here because this is a kitty
litter corner and oh my god luckily the
cats have not messed with it at all
at all they haven't messed with the
christmas tree i'm so
happy i'm so happy they haven't messed
with it but yeah i also put this garland
around and then there's like these
window things there's like a santa there
christmas tree there where i put garland
all around
the couch oh and also snowflakes all
over the windows
he still hasn't noticed i'm here he's
really concentrated how cute good job
honey
it looks great
[Music]
really
[Music]
good job honey it looks great
that's so cute oh i just passed by this
really cool thing okay i this is how i
know i'm old because i am so freaking
excited over a trash can okay so you
guys know the trash can that we already
have so this trash can here it's like uh
like voice automated or whatever like if
i speak to it it'll open like i could
say open can
it opens it's a freaking cool trash can
which is a gift from wong fu by the way
so thank you so we separate our trash
where it's anything stinky like any food
stuff or like like mushy stuff that will
make our trash smell we actually put it
in
this trash thing which no longer has a
bag because we don't use it anymore but
this guy was actually here for the
longest time and we had to put it inside
the cabinet because our cat zoe decided
to turn into a dog now and started
attacking that bag there was this one
day we came home and there was like all
that like the food scraps and stuff like
shredded everywhere all on the floor
horrible or i'm like what happened cat
we've been having this here for like two
years it's been fine all of a sudden now
you want to attack any like crumb of
food that we leave anywhere in the
kitchen so now we have to make sure
anytime we cook we have to put every
everything away like everything has to
be cleaned because this cat will get to
it it's been really annoying but anyway
so that's why we moved it to inside the
cabinet but then the other day casey and
i we were out shopping and we saw this
cute edition
look how freaking cute
it's a it's literally the exact same
kind of trash situation uh but for for
composting we don't compost but it's
literally for the same use which is to
put stinky trash no i'm not talking to
you i'm not talking to you we're talking
about your your little friend here your
little brother now you got a little
brother look how freaking cute i cannot
get over it i was so happy bringing this
home i'm like look our trash can is
pregnant too
it has its own baby
attached to it i freaking love it oh my
god that's what i'm saying like that's
how you know you're old
the trash can gets you excited okay
another thing i have to talk about
because i'm like staring at this guy
here it's refrigerator
okay
this refrigerator has given us so many
headaches you guys i do not recommend
this ge
refrigerator that has the keurig
right here when we first bought this
we're like oh how cool we can make
coffee with the refrigerator it's really
convenient we actually use it a lot for
the hot water and all that okay but the
reason why i'm so like
about it is because the freezer has
stopped working on us and the ice maker
like whenever the ice maker is on for
some reason like it starts leaking and
like the fan stops working so all the
cold air starts going to the
refrigerator and so our freezer
defrosted everything because it wasn't
cold but our refrigerator
started freezing because all the cold
was like being stuck in the refrigerator
it was ridiculous man we actually we had
this day where the whole day were like
we should have vlogged this day oh my
god this day was eventful but we
actually had to hit up our neighbors
and ask them like oh my god do you have
any room in your refrigerator because
our freezer just completely stopped
working and so luckily our our neighbors
across the way they were like oh yeah
don't worry we have extra room in our
garage refrigerator we're like you guys
have an extra refrigerator in the garage
it's genius so they actually helped us
out and we kept our food there for like
a week and i had the repair guy come
over and he's like all right we're gonna
have to do some major like open heart
surgery type of procedure on this
refrigerator to make it work and it's so
annoying because when the the
maintenance guy is here the freezer all
of a sudden decides to work it's like
are you kidding me you work when you
don't need to
and then when you need to you're not
working that was really annoying after
we heard about our neighbors having a
refrigerator in the garage we're like oh
my god we should have a refrigerator in
our garage too in case this guy breaks
on us again because that was horrible
all of our stuff defrosted and we had to
throw away a lot of things so i went on
offer up and i found
this really good refrigerator it's a
samsung it looks practically brand new
the guys had it for like five years he
was moving he was selling it for 200
bucks and i'm like oh my god this is a
really good refrigerator for just 200
bucks we need to jump on this and the
reason why i'm saying we should have
vlogged that day is because it was a
mission this guy was like back and forth
between selling it to me and someone
else and then the guy was like i'm sorry
the other person says that they're on
their way already i'm gonna sell it to
them and i was like no we need this
refrigerator luckily though that the
other people they were like oh
um we can't make it at the time we said
we are some of the guys like if you can
beat them here i'll give you the
refrigerator so i'm like yes let's go
luckily he was only like 10 minutes away
so we got there got the fridge we took
casey's telluride turns out the fridge
doesn't fit in the tellurides but
luckily the guy was like oh don't worry
we can use my truck just load it up to
my truck and we'll take it so thank you
guy so much he actually helped us bring
it over in his truck but then when we
get here oh my god we get here we plug
in the refrigerator to the wall to the
outlet and our entire power of the whole
garage went out our water heaters
connected to that same wall actually
like just the garage we didn't have hot
water for a whole night because we were
like how are we going to
reset this we went to the circuit
breaker we flipped all the switches
nothing worked we have a gi gfi
reset thing didn't work it was crazy
right case that day
i'm like we couldn't shower we couldn't
couldn't use hot water
oh we couldn't close the garage door
because the the garage power was out
yeah we're gonna use your garage door we
had to manually close it
it was insane so anyway the next day we
call we call an electrician
we're like hey
i don't know what's happening we reset
everything we could please come over
help us out so then an electrician came
over and he was like doing his testing
stuff he's like i have no idea like it
should be working like i don't know
what's i don't know what's wrong there
must be another gfi reset button
somewhere you guys haven't seen in this
garage so let me show you so if you look
way over there there's that gfi reset
button thing and that's the one we kept
clicking on to reset the whole power for
the garage but then when the electrician
guy came he was like there must be
another one
and he found it
here right behind these cabinets that i
also need to show you guys how i built
by the way i haven't finished that vlog
but he saw this somehow he found it and
that was what reset the power to the
entire garage and that's how we were
able to fix
this power outage situation that we got
from the brand new fridge and we were so
which is this one by the way we were so
like freaking out because we're like we
just bought this brand new fridge
and it just wiped out the power and then
we tried connecting it with an extension
cord from inside the house and it it
like blocked out that outlet too so we
had to reset it on the circuit breaker
so we're like is the fridge fried did we
just ruin the brand new fridge that we
bought like what's happening but luckily
the electrician guy figured it out now
we have a garage refrigerator we put all
of casey's medication here
and some extra almond milk
and some drinks but you really what
we're using it for
is the freezer because we don't trust
the freezer
inside the house anymore so all of our
frozen stuff is out here
now we know we can
we can rely on this refrigerator but we
have so much stuff in here
it's crazy
so you might be thinking like wait so
you sent out an electrician just so he
could push a button that's a big old
waste of his time i would agree with you
but we ended up hiring him to install a
new outlet for the tesla charger so
if his trip wasn't wasted he actually
installed the 520 i think it's called
so a bigger outlet so now my car is
charging a lot faster these days so all
that refrigerator craziness stuff that
happened actually
worked out because then now we have a
faster plug for the tesla and now we
charge it on this side and not on this
side anymore which means i got to move
that cord
management thing on the other side yeah
that was the whole refrigerator thing it
was
crazy anyway i got to make casey his
breakfast oh my god i've been talking
for a long time
red
there's no more red oh no
he's gonna get end pieces for his
breakfast
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh so funny that's so small
[Music]
[Applause]
take your vitamins
[Music]
breakfast delivery
enjoy thank you
i love how the cats are just on the bed
too it's cute my roommates
meet the mates the flat mates
all right enjoy thank you so much you're
welcome
okay so after i make him breakfast and
by the way remember i said it's not
morning it's technically like lunch
because it's like almost two o'clock
sleep schedule has been out of whack
because
now me being in third trimester i have
fatigue again which means just like in
first trimester which is throwing off my
sleep schedule like crazy because i am
now like taking naps throughout the day
which means i stay up later at night
like for example last night we didn't go
to sleep till 2 a.m and that's what's
happening we are going to sleep really
late
waking up late
um so that's why breakfast right now
it's coming at 2 p.m i've been making
smoothies i've been using a whole bunch
of ingredients like chia seeds have you
guys ever used chia seeds because i'm
new to this chia seeds life
and i've just been like sprinkling a
tiny bit into my smoothies in the
morning
and it definitely gives it like
a slimier texture which i'm like
is it supposed to be like this i don't
know um but apparently there's like a
ton of health benefits to chia seeds so
that's why i've been
just sprinkling them on my stuff so
that's what i'll be doing right now my
oatmeal and my smoothie and then after
we have a an appointment to get to so i
think that might be the extent of my
updates for you guys but i don't know
we'll see what happens
[Applause]
yeah today we're doing extra spinach
because it's going bad on me
[Music]
so yeah these days um i've just been
making breakfast and then eating alone
because
casey's upstairs in the office try not
to get me sick wearing a mask but you
know what though i didn't update you
guys so remember last time um
we were talking about me getting my
gestational diabetes test well it turns
out that that first one the one hour
test i failed it but like barely by a
little bit
and so which means that they found too
much sugar in my blood so i had to go in
for a three hour test and i didn't film
that one but that one was
it was nuts oh my god do i stop my
bruise yeah look i still have a bruise
on my arm
so that one i had to fast and then i
went into the office they drew my blood
for the first round and then they had me
take the drink and they didn't have any
more of the powdered drink because this
birth center is closing down so they
didn't restock on the good stuff so i
had to take the nasty stuff and some of
you guys are commenting that that orange
drink isn't that bad girl
it was just as bad as i remembered 13
years ago this drink is disgusting and
maybe i'm just like sensitive to the
sugar i don't know you guys have
different palette i don't know but this
drink is
disgusting and i had to i had to drink
that one and so i'm like dang it i
didn't get to avoid drinking that one
one hour later i go in they draw my
blood and then i had to do that three
more times so a total of four blood
draws so she kept pricking the same part
which is like the very center part of my
arm and she did that one three times and
then the fourth time because that third
time that she did it i'm like oh man my
vein is is like getting tired like it
hurts so in the fourth time she did it
where it's super bruised and that was
just one prick there where i'm like what
the heck lady that was just one blood
draw and look at this insane bruise but
anyway i got my test results for that
second glucose test and i pass
so i don't have gestational diabetes you
guys ah i made it and my numbers were
really great too it wasn't like i barely
passed like they were really good
um so i'm really really relieved about
that so that's another update for you
guys okay now i'm gonna have my
breakfast
[Music]
you